hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute cat mario oder was auch immer das
hier oben heißt so ich hatte eigentlich
erst gedacht an verzocken allerdings ich
zeige euch mal kurz wie die website
aussieht wenn ich hier auf anti mario
punkt kommen bin geht dieses spiel
einfach nicht
es ist einfach weiß deswegen spielen wir
heute kuba
wir haben zwei ausländer die seite
wieder heftig oder hierauf werden hier
pro danke jetzt weiß ich auf jeden fall
wie man spielen wenn ich hier oben drauf
drücken können wir ich habe drei leben
jetzt können wir laufen und so sterben
wir denken bestimmt das ist jetzt zum
mega siedler aber er schlittert du die
ganze zeit an
ganz ruhig ich warte hier bis die leute
wechseln was passiert kann ich doch
darauf kann töten was bringt dieses ding
das macht überhaupt ist es bei den
sachen
das ist böse oder und wenn ich hier
drauf springe dann bekommen die münze
und kann ich ihn
ich bin immer so geflasht von ontario
weil dazu sodass jetzt beispielsweise
einfach mal so ein blog unter mg
verschwinden würde
falls euch fragt wieso ich bin mir sagen
jetzt anfallenden ich kann typisches
video von lukaku beim landen
ich kann auf jeden fall richtig gut auf
englisch zählen schaut man kann hier gar
nicht mehr weiter zurück ich bin hier
quasi jetzt einfach gefallen wenn ihr an
per mario die videos noch nicht kennen
verlinkt ich euch hier ein oh mein gott
- ein leben alles klar was bringen leben
wenn die einfach in den minusbereich
gehen
das macht gar keinen sinn
alles klar ich verlinke euch das an ver
mario video mal dort da könnt ihr euch
das anschauen das wollte ich eigentlich
erst das ging ja nicht okay hier drüber
so jetzt kann ich hier drauf jetzt kurz
hier das was hier untergeht genau und
was hat mir das jetzt gebracht ich
dachte ich werde jetzt größer oder kann
in mein gott aber es passiert wirklich
nicht aber das ziel kopf das war gerade
nun
mir kommt sofort ich heute überhaupt
nicht mehr kommen
mir kommt es so vor als könnte ich heute
überhaupt nicht kommentieren weil ich
einfach mich zu megawatt nimm scheiße
hier kommt es so vor als könnte ich
heute mein gott okay ist wahrscheinlich
die verteilt hat schon gewöhnt von mir
deswegen muss ich mich dafür eine wolke
eishockey es ist jetzt komplett egal was
jetzt für sachen ich wüsste genau ins
loch ist klar
ihr seid meine verteilt hat v ich weiß
welche spiele ich nie wieder spielen
werde jetzt ist diese katze gezwungen
ganz schillig hierüber hoher ich hasse
mein leben ich dachte am anfang hat
wirklich dass das ganze spiel relativ
cool ist weil das richtige aus das ist
jetzt nicht wahr die ersten sprünge
seien halt recht idee oder gar demski
nein wolke ich vertraue dir nicht schön
hier über schöne scheiße mario ich
gewinnen jetzt java eine loewe hat angst
vor mir jetzt da kommt eine rolle
ich bin nicht wirklich gerade noch am
ende o mein gott was mach ich bin jetzt
nicht gerade am ende wirklich nach dem
ziel getötet worden ist da der ernst von
dem spiel dieses spiel sollte treu mario
nicht hat mario heißen bei den ganzen
scheiß machen die immer passieren
was soll das ganz locker lässt sich hier
über die alle rüber springen und jetzt
beim ziel vermutlich mal was mache ich
denn jetzt ich versuche mal ganz
leichtes ziel
wow geil jetzt bin ich wieder hier
drunter klar geht mario jeder noch jetzt
kann ich nicht mal mehr sterben hier und
ich springe ich mache ich nicht gerne
einfach das video zu beenden war ich
habe